we were scheduled to have four more
democratic primary elections yesterday
one was canceled that's Ohio thanks to
Republican governor Mike DeWine deciding
that because of coronavirus Ohio would
be postponing its primary in the end it
didn't matter the three that we had went
to Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders has
announced he will be reassessing his
campaign which is political code four
it's over let's look at the numbers
let's look at what took place three
elections happened last night Arizona
Florida and Illinois going into
yesterday in terms of Delegates Joe
Biden was leading Bernie Sanders by 151
delegates 894 to 743 the results in
yesterday's three primaries are and of
course we like to compare to the polling
in Arizona Biden was winning by 18 in
the polls but won only by 12 in Florida
Biden was winning by 39 and won by 39
and an Illinois Biden was winning by 29
and won by 23 Biden underperforming the
polls in two of yesterday's three
primaries this now pushes the delegate
numbers to 11 47 for Biden 861 for
Bernie doing the math for you that's a
286 delegate lead for Joe Biden now as I
had said before if the delegate lead
ends at more than 200 after the March 17
primaries and certainly if it ends at
more than 250 Bernie should suspend his
campaign simply because he has no path
to the nomination and indeed Bernie
Sanders has announced he is now
assessing his campaign he says in the
following weeks now this again is how
you translate Telegraph in political
code that it's over it's just a matter
of when and how they structure his exit
in order to be as graceful as possible
and to be clear this really isn't close
it's not you know maybe if he sticks it
out it is not close it's not clear
Bernie has a path to winning any more
states maybe one here or there the
popular vote count is not close it is
now about 2.5 million votes offer in
favor of Joe
I said yesterday you know it may end up
larger than two million and I
underestimated by about 25% Joe Biden
leading by two point five million votes
it's a massive lead and this is not
about you know doing more post mortems
we've done post mortems we're in the
middle of a crisis with the virus this
is simply about it's it's not at all
close and again when bernie will suspend
we don't know we know that there was
scheduled to be a March 24 primary in
Georgia which Biden was going to win
easily that's been postponed because of
the virus Puerto Rico scheduled to vote
on March 29 in April on April 4th Alaska
and Hawaii were scheduled as well as
Wyoming again not not very many
delegates there April 7th in Wisconsin
28th of April we were getting to
Connecticut Delaware Maryland New York
Pennsylvania and Rhode Island we have no
idea whether those were going to be
postponed or will be but every
indication I mean listen it's we just
don't know it's possible by the time you
listen to this Bernie will be out it's
possible Bernie really will take a
couple of weeks given that we don't have
any primaries coming up in the immediate
other than Puerto Rico scheduled 11 days
from now I don't know it's not clear
what it makes sense to do and of course
we will be forced into discussing are we
going to have conventions are we going
to you know how will the virus affect
the remaining trajectory of the primary
the primary in all but the most
technical sense is over as Joe Biden has
won three more primaries and easily and
the big news Bernie Sanders assessing
his campaign we deal with things as they
are not as as not as we would wish them
to be and these are the numbers we are
dealing with I still had people tweet
angrily tweeting me today when I was
commenting on Bernie's announcement that
he is assessing which is code for ending
soon saying I am redoubling down my
efforts and donating money to Bernie I I
mean I don't get you know you whatever
your financial situation is if you want
to donate to Bernie now do it but to
some degree it seems like denialism at
this point in time and I don't totally
get it that's money that could be used
you know it donate to some issue
Payne if you don't care about Biden
beating beating Trump fine but I don't
know why when Bernie says he's
reassessing the campaign you you would
you would continue donating but maybe
somebody can let me know this is the
path forward we will have more coverage
one of our sponsors is privacy comm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy comm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cashback and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a twenty five dollar a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy
calm slash Pakman
you